the economy performs slightly better
than expected in January bouncing back
from a flat December with a growth of
0.3 percent in January that's higher
certainly than economists expected it's
not uh overall good news three months
going back from January was was flat at
zero percent if you take the year two
January as a whole there was also no
growth but what drove this bounce back
the number of things that returned in
January schools went back education's
counted in the GDP figures the office
for National statistics say the return
of the Premier League after the World
Cup break in December that also helped
increase spending in Services uh human
health activities is the ons rather
dryly describes growing to the gym
that's another driver of services uh
bouncing back and lifting growth uh 0.3
growth above expectations and canceling
out declines in construction and
Manufacturing which speak of the rather
more stubborn underlying trends that are
depressing growth in the economy but a
little glim of something to uh perhaps
not celebrate but be pleased about as
the chancellor prepares for his budget
next Wednesday